[Music]
one absolutely central feature to both
the narrative setting and to the
plot
of philip k dick's novel to android's
dream of electric sheep is the status of
animals both real
and electric we could say fake and that
wouldn't be completely off although
people
do in many respects relate to these
electric electronic replica animals
as if they were the real thing and
they're made as
similar as as possible to the real thing
so
in this narrative setting animals have
become
pretty rare in part because of the
catastrophe that has happened not just
to animals but to the environment in
general and to
human beings as well
so here's the the setting
no one remembered today why the war had
come about or who if anyone had won
the dust that had contaminated most of
the planet's surface had originated in
no country and no one even the wartime
enemy had planned on it first strangely
the owls had died at the time it had
seemed almost funny the fat fluffy white
birds lying here and there in yards and
on the streets coming out no earlier
than twilight as they had while alive
the owls
escaped notice medieval plagues had
manifested themselves in a similar way
in the form of many dead rats
this plague however had descended from
above after the owls of course the other
birds followed but by then the mystery
had been grasped and understood a meager
colonization program had been underway
so they could they continue that and it
talks a little bit about you know the
carrot and stick of emigrating but the
key thing here is that
not only is human life becoming somewhat
precarious you know men have to walk
around in lead cod pieces and you know
there's there's tests to make sure that
people haven't been degenerating in
other respects
the animals have in large part begun to
die off
and there are replicas as we're going to
see of owls but
there's
you know very few animals left and the
ones that are left are
quite valuable so the animals themselves
are you know in this this book that gets
talked about it many times
sydney's animal and fowl catalog which
comes out in a number of supplements
people carry it around with them and
whip it out so they can see you know
what's actually available and what the
costs are to be sort of like
what you know americans at least i don't
know if this is common in other places
have kelly's blue book for car values
you can get it out and you can actually
go online and check it out as well
and there's another really
important
non-economic
feature to this as well
human beings we can say definitely that
throughout most of our history while
some people are empathetic and caring
towards animals other people view them
as mere beasts of burden
resources to be exploited there are even
a lot of people who are abusive and even
sadistic towards animals or selectively
so right so dogs and cats we treat them
nice but rats you know oh that's vermin
and you know a lot of people don't like
spiders we're gonna talk about spiders
in a bit
um but they'll you know like ladybugs
and dragonflies and stuff like that
in this world this uh
world of
deckards and androids and stuff like
that most human beings do in fact
have empathy
and exhibit care
towards animals and that's part of what
sets human beings at least the ones who
aren't institutionalized
apart from the androids who lack empathy
in fact that can be made the entire
basis
for a test to distinguish these
otherwise very very realistic
human mimicking androids apart from
genuine
human beings and this human empathy and
care extends even to electric animals
as a substitute although it's it's felt
to be
a little bit
day classy a little bit shameful
to have electric animals in place of the
real ones
so
rick deckard has
a number of connections
with animals we see in chapter one
there's this scene where he's talking
well with his neighbor bill barbour who
has a horse who's actually
pregnant and rick says wow you so pretty
soon you're gonna have two horses and
rick has got his electric sheep this is
you know the title do androids dream of
electric sheep right and now notice this
is kind of interesting he says
of course some of their animals
undoubtedly consisted of electronic
circuitry fakes he of course had never
nosed into the matter any more than they
his neighbors had pried into the real
workings of his sheep nothing could be
more impolite to ask there to say is
your sheep genuine would be a worse
breach of manners than to inquire
whether a citizen's teeth hair or
internal organs would test a test out
authentic and so he's talking with this
neighbor who's got a much bigger better
animal who's actually pregnant who's
gone to great expense you know he says i
bought some of the highest quality
fertilizing plasma available in
california through inside contacts i
have with the state animal husbandry
board and risk rick then says ever
thought of selling your horse
and barbara said it would be immoral to
sell my horse well sell the colt then
having two animals is more immoral than
not having any
and
they start you know discussing it and it
turns out that you can't really get
a horse that that easily it takes a lot
of connections the barber says there's a
reason why sydney's doesn't have any
percher and colts in stock percher and
colts don't just change hands they're
too scarce even relatively inferior ones
so you know this is a
central idea rick then actually reveals
to his neighbor
that it's a fake sheep and he says see
you understand now why i want your cult
so badly and then rick tells a little
bit of origin story here
um
barbara says has it always been this way
and rick says no i had a real sheep
originally my wife's father gave it to
us outright when he emigrated then about
a year ago remember that time i took it
to the vet you were up here that morning
when i came out and find it lying on its
side and it couldn't get up
sheep get strange diseases or put it
another way sheep get a lot of diseases
but the symptoms are always the same the
sheep can't get up there's no way to
tell how serious it is whether it's a
sprained leg or the animal is dying of
tetanus that's what mine died of tetanus
it ate a wire off of a hay bale
got tetanus a scratch
and then it died and so
rick then uh had a fake sheep made
in its its place and he tells us a
little bit about what's going on
um
before that though he says i've put as
much time and attention into caring for
it as i did when it was real but
barber says it's not the same
but almost
you feel the same doing it you have to
keep your eye on it exactly as you did
when it was really alive because they
break down and then everyone in the
building knows i've had at the repair
shop six times mostly little
malfunctions but if anyone saw them you
know if the voice tape broke or got
fouled it wouldn't stop buying they'd
recognize it as a mechanical
rather than an organic
breakdown
and so that's that's an interesting
little vignette there
as deckard finds that he's got the
possibility of coming into some money he
considers purchasing
a fake ostrich and engages in some
wheeling and dealing trying to get the
shop to come down significantly
the price he doesn't end up doing that
but after he does retire
the or you know
he's involved in the retiring since he
doesn't actually
do all of the killing himself the three
androids and has the bounties coming to
him he uses that as a
down payment to
purchase a goat and there's a very
interesting discussion
that's taking place between deckard
and um
the
people who are are selling them
um
here we go
so
he starts out by talking about he's at a
store and he says you know
what about those rabbits over there and
he says you know if you have a down
payment of the the amount of money that
you've got i can make you an owner of
something a lot better than a pair of
rabbits
what about a goat
rick says well i haven't thought about a
goat and now notice how it's being
discussed may i ask if this represents a
new price bracket for you it's sort of
like pricing cars or something like that
and you know rick asks well what are the
advantages to goats the distinct
advantage of a goat is that it can be
taught to butt anyone who tries to steal
it and then rick says well that's not an
awful lot of help and then he says a
goat is loyal and it has a free natural
soul which no chain cage can chain up
there is one exceptional additional
feature about goats oftentimes when you
invest in an animal you find and take it
home you find some morning it's eaten
something radioactive and died a goat
isn't bothered by contaminated quasi
foodstuffs it can eat eclectically even
items that would fell a cow or horse or
most especially a cat as a long-term
investment we feel that the goat
especially the female offers unbeatable
advantages to the serious animal owner
so there's this patter going on between
them this is a good salesman right
and so
rick actually does buy the goat and you
know puts the money down signs the
contract
then takes it home to his wife and um
here we go he tells her come up to the
roof i want to show you something you
bought an animal you shouldn't have
gotten it without me i have a right to
participate in the decision and he says
i wanted it to be a surprise and then
she she comes over and she sees the goat
she circles around she says is it really
real
it's not false
he says absolutely real unless they
swindled me
and she said she says it's a goat a
black nubian goat and rick says female
so maybe later on we can mate her and
we'll get milk out of her
of which we can make cheese
and
you know
this really raises
her her spirits she put her hand gently
on his shoulder lean toward him and
kissed him uh much love and very much
pleasure she's talking about her life
and he he asks her does this cure your
depression it cures mine
and then she says something really quite
interesting
yes this cures my depression
now we can tell everybody that our sheep
is fake
and rick says well we don't have to do
that and she says but we can
see now we have nothing to hide what
we've always wanted is come true it's a
dream
now unfortunately the goat is going to
arrive at a bad end i won't reveal
all of that to you you can read the book
and find out there is a third animal
that winds up playing an important role
which is a toad which deckard finds out
in the desert
he's very despondent he's you know out
in the wasteland
and he's about to call his wife
and then
he says he set the receiver back down
and did not take his eyes from the spot
that had moved outside the car the bulge
in the ground among the stones an animal
he said to himself
and his heart lugged under the excessive
load the shock of recognition i know
what it is
he realized i've never seen one before
but i know it from the old nature films
they show on government tv
they're extinct he said to himself
swiftly he dragged out as much creased
sydney's turned the pages with twitching
fingers
toad
buffonedai all varieties
e extinct for years now
the critter most precious to wilbur
mercer along with a donkey so he gets a
box and he goes out and gets the toad
and puts it into the box
he brushes away the loose soil from from
the toad he says it did not seem to
object but of course it was not aware of
his existence
when he lifted the toad out he felt its
particular peculiar coolness in his
hands its body seemed dry
and wrinkled and then he says to himself
so this is what mercer sees
life which we can no longer distinguish
life carefully buried up to its forehead
in the carcass of a dead world
in every cinder of the universe mercer
probably perceives inconspicuous life
now i know
he thought and once having seen through
mercer's eyes i will probably
never stop this is
producing things have produced a
important change in him and the toad
allows this change to be sort of
reflected upon and catalyzed he gets
home he brings it into his wife she
looks at it in the box you know he's
totally exhausted he's resting and then
she you know finds out oh it's actually
an electric
toad but it's still good to have and
there's uh
here we go
um
she flipped the panel open oh his face
fell by degrees yeah i see you're right
he gazed mutely at the false animal he
took it back from her fiddled with the
legs as if baffled and then he carefully
replaced it in the box and she says
maybe i shouldn't have told you about it
being electrical
she put her hand out touched his arm she
felt guilty sensing the effect it had on
him the change
no rick said i'm glad to know or rather
he became silent i prefer to know and
here in this passage
this chapter we actually get
one of the best lines of the entire book
so he says
[Music]
i'll be okay
the spider mercer gave the chicken head
isadore which we're going to talk about
as well it probably was artificial too
but it doesn't matter
the electrical things have their lives
too
paltry
as those lives are
the rosen association is this massive
conglomerate with lots and lots of power
and connections and deckard actually
goes there early on in the the story to
check out the the new androids right and
meets rachel rosen
and while they're there it seems like
you know so typical for what
corporations get away with they have
access to animals that otherwise
would be gone so
um
here we go
a powerful corporation
he realized would be able to afford this
in the back of his mind he anticipated
such a collection
he walked quietly away from the girl
toward the closest pen already he could
smell them the several sense of the
creature standing or sitting or in the
case of what appeared to be a raccoon
asleep never
in his life had he personally seen a
raccoon he knew the animal only from 3d
films shown on
television
he brings out his uh sydney's and looks
up the raccoon with all its price
listing sizzi's catalog simply listed
the price at which the last transaction
involving a raccoon had taken place it
was astronomical his name is bill the
girl said from behind and bill the
raccoon we acquired him just last year
from a subsidiary
corporation
and then rick says a major manufacturer
of androids
invested surplus capital on living
animals and then rachel rosen said look
at the owl
here i'll wake it up for you she started
towards a small distant cage
in the center of which jutted up a
branching dead tree there are no owls he
started to say or so we've been told
and
she says he says it's artificial and
then she says no it's not
but sydney's listening
the girl said we don't buy from sydney's
or from any animal dealer all our
purchases are from private parties and
the prices we pay aren't reported also
we have our own naturalists they're
working up in canada there's still a lot
of forest left comparatively speaking
enough for small animals and once in a
while
a
bird and so
there's another interesting reflection
here he thought about his need for a
real animal within him an actual hatred
once more manifested towards his
electric sheep which he had to tend had
to care about as if it lived the tyranny
of an object it doesn't know
i exist he had never thought about this
before the similarity between an
electric animal and an andy
um and he asked if you sold your owl how
much would you want for it we would
never sell our owl now they try to use
the owl as a way to bribe him and
at the very end of this discussion
uh when you know he is has basically
flipped the trap uh on
them right they say how would you like
to to own an owl right and at the very
end
he's leaving and
eldon rosen says
it doesn't matter the owl is artificial
there are no owls so it's all been kind
of
a sham
um
speaking of shams we have isidore a
major character in this and the van ness
pet hospital
they are part of the
fake that takes in electric sheep or
cats or whatever and then they give them
whatever
checkups treatments they need there and
return them to their owners in
this this chapter chapter 7 a real cat
is dying and isidore has it and thinks
that it's actually
a fake and he brings it to the
animal hospital and
a lot of
um
back and forth discussion
ensues slot actually the owner says it's
the waste that gets me the loss of one
more living creature couldn't you tell
isidore didn't you notice the difference
and then milt one of the other
people there says i don't think as
isidor can tell the difference to him
they're all alive fake false animals
included he probably tried to save it
and then isidore has to make a video
call to the
owners uh the pilsens uh the wife is
there the the husband had like thrown
the cat into his arms and left and they
go back and forth
deciding about what they're going to do
and as it turns out she's amenable
to having a fake maid
for her husband who hopefully won't
actually notice the difference but
there's reflection in here saying if
you're a pet owner you're going to
notice the difference
we also have phil resch
potentially an android
one of the people that is is working at
the
fake police station
and we find that phil is really worried
about this he says
it's not just false memory structures i
own an animal not a false one but the
real thing i love the squirrel deckard
every goddamn morning i feed it and
change its papers you know clean up its
cage and then in the evening when i get
off work i let it loose in my aft and it
runs all over the place it has a wheel
in its cage ever seen a squirrel running
inside a wheel
and you know it keeps going on and a
little bit later
in chapter 12
phil says did you ever hear of an andy
an android having a pet of any sort
and deckard says
for some obscure reason he felt the need
to be brutally honest
perhaps he had already been begun
preparing himself for what lay ahead in
two cases that i know of andy's owned
and cared for
animals but it's rare from what i've
been able to learn it generally fails
the andy is unable to keep the animal
alive it
animals require an environment of warmth
to flourish except reptiles and insects
and so
phil says would a squirrel need that an
atmosphere of love because buffy is
doing fine his sleek is an otter i comb
and groom him
every
day and so the question is
is this revelatory of the fact that
phil rash isn't an android or
is he some sort of weird exception
we also see isidore engaging with the
androids who have effectively taken over
his place and
a you know as it's narrated rather
horrible
uh experience that's going on both for
the spider and for
isidore himself he finds a spider
in the here we go something small moved
in the dust he dropped the suitcases he
whipped out a plastic medicine bottle
which like everyone else he carried for
just this a spider undistinguished but
alive and he puts it in there tells the
androids we've i've found a spider and
then what is their reaction
pris says you know what i think jr
i think it doesn't need all those legs
eight
irma guard beatty said why couldn't it
get by on four cut off four and c so she
gets out cuticle scissors and a weird
tear strikes jd is a door um they they
take the spider and uh
pris says it probably won't be able to
run as fast but there's nothing for it
to catch around here anyway it'll die
anyhow and isidor begins pleading and he
says please don't mutilate it and she
starts snipping off the spider's legs
bit by bit
then when it only has four legs
it stops crawling around on the table
and
they get out of flame to try to get it
to move right
um
roy gets out a book of matches the
spider crawls feebly away irma guard
says i was right didn't i say it could
walk with only four legs and then she
peers at isidore and says what's the
matter you didn't lose anything we'll
pay you what's it called the sydney's
catalog says don't be so grim
is in and so he goes to the empathy box
and he has an experience in which mercer
brings the spider out of the dust and
gives it to him and he goes out of the
apartment
puts the spider down
this is where he encounters the bounty
hunter rick deckard who then is going to
go in and kill
the killers kill the androids but it
shows you something about the
mentality at least of these androids
that they show zero empathy towards this
tiny vulnerable and valuable
creature so
these are
some of the high points and most
interesting
passages dealing with this important
theme of animal life both real and
electric
into android's dream of electric sheep
you